marcel bénézet bonjour merci n'a jamais
été notre invitation ce matin alain
dernier service donc ce soir jusqu'à 21h
dans quel état d'esprit se trouvent les
professionnels du secteur
ils sont abattus je vous assurer qu'ils
sont complètement
c'est un coup de massue supplémentaire
que nous avons reçus parce que nous
sommes nous avons seront quelques-uns
depuis le mois de mai mais au début du
mois de juin mais maman met donc en
avait réouvert mais si vous voulez
aujourd'hui c'est un coup dur parce que
ces races et rapides devront fermer nos
établissements ce soir nous avons du
stock
nous avons bien sûr prévu de nous allons
entrer des marchandises que nous aurons
du mal à écouler donc c'est encore une
perte sèche ça va être donné à des
associations ça va être distribué rien
ne sera ajouté je l'espère mais c'est un
coup dur je compte beaucoup sur le les
aides de l'état parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous allons être fermée totalement
nous avons le problème des loyers qui
n'est pas réglé hier j'avais une réunion
avec un groupe de travail pour
travailler trouver les solutions pour
ses loyers envers d âme face aux
propriétaires risquent rien qui sont en
attente de leur loyer et qui parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le point le point
fort c'est le loyer parce que nos
salariés vont être au chômage partiel
on a réglé le problème ou presque réglé
le problème des 10% de congés payés qui
restait à charge
je pense que ça ça va être fait mais
aujourd'hui les mémés restaurateurs et
cafetiers limonadiers et traiteurs sont
en arrêt des hôteliers sont dans un état
moral désespérés parce qu'il se demande
de tarbes à finir ce terme à finir cette
pandémie parce qu'aujourd'hui on en
connaît on n'a pas le bout de la
lorgnette on nous dit le 1er décembre le
1er décembre nous annoncer que c'est pas
suffisant et on va nous poser au 15
décembre pour essayer de passer les
fêtes de noël ensemble en famille mais
tout ça c'est que des prévisions et je
pense que nous partons pour une période
compliquée difficile pour notre
profession qui déjà un genou à deux jeux
les genoux à terre on a tué la
gastronomie français nous sommes le pays
de la gastronomie est aujourd'hui la
notion de la gastronomie française en
france n'existe plus alors emmanuel
macron il hier soir lors de son
allocution a dit que dans quinze jours
on ferait de nouveau le point justement
pour voir si
certains secteurs pouvaient réouvrir je
pense qu'il faisait allusion bien
évidemment au secteur de la restauration
un secteur qui est vraiment au plus mal
on sait qu'il ya énormément
d'établissements
voilà qui ont totalement fermé leurs
portes
lors du premier confinement pour les
autres ceux qui sont encore présents est
ce que vous pensez qu'ils vont s'en
sortir avec justement les aides qu'a
proposé qu'annoncé hier soir emmanuel
macron oui mais les allées faut qu'ils
arrivent très vite et est ce qu'elles
vont arriver très vite sur je ne sais
pas je l'espère je le demande nous
demandons à bercy dès que les aides
arrivent très vite aujourd'hui le pge
n'a servi qu'à rembourser des loyers à
payer quelques les abonnements à payer
tout le quantum été la clé dans une
serrure d'un établissement vous avez des
charges fixes aujourd'hui c'est sûr je
fixe ne sont pas couverts n'a
aujourd'hui nous allons fermer et nous
emmènent même pas un centime de recettes
pour y faire face
parce qu'il faut savoir que nous avons
ouvert nos établissements depuis le mois
de juin avec 50 % de capacité ce qui ne
permet pas ce qui ne permet pas de
couvrir les frais aujourd'hui nous avons
une monnaie modèle économique
il ne tient plus donc j'en remets la
situation est très grave et je suis très
inquiet je pense que j'avais dit rendre
conscients de nos établissements
risquent de disparaître
mais aujourd'hui vous avez l'hôtellerie
qui est derrière qui va suivre et vous
avez je pense qu'on va arriver à une des
moulins destruction de deux entreprises
vers 40 % sur la totalité du territoire
mais en plus c'est le nombre de salariés
parce que nous avons quand même nous
sommes le chêne nous avait derrière nous
les restaurateurs vous avez les
agriculteurs vous avez toute une chaîne
alimentaire qui est très importante et
qui est elle mise à mal aussi
et ça c'est très très bien parce
qu'aujourd'hui je me demande dans quel
état on va sortir de cette crise
beaucoup de patrons du secteur ne disent
ne pas comprendre la fermeture de leur
établissement de l'impression que l'on
sache à sur leurs activités c'est un
sentiment vous partagez ce mais le
prendre des billets là c'est compliqué
c'est très grave parce qu'on pourrait
nous reprocher sur l'été restait ouvert
mais effectivement dans nos
établissements n'ont aucune preuve comme
quoi des posteurs des grappes de foyers
ont été ont été reconnus chez nous c'est
vrai que le fait d'être à table autour
d'un restaurant dans un resto on est
face à face à peu mais on sait avec des
gens qu'on connaît
on a mis le main ce qu'on a renforcé le
protocole en a on nous on a fait tout ce
qu'on nous a demandé et on l'a bien fait
effectivement il ya eu des témoins
élève cela il fallait les sanctionner
mais nous on a généralement les
restaurateurs et les cafés qui avait
suivi le protocole sanitaire et ça se
passait très bien
aujourd'hui nous sommes vraiment
désespérer d'une fermeture totale et
contraintes
merci beaucoup monsieur marcel bénézet
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que là je vais retrouver
tout de suite votre titre je rappelle
donc vous êtes le président
du groupement national des indépendants
de l'hôtellerie et de la restauration